we're going to begin with this one of
Washington's great annual events is now
on hold
president Trump has decided not to give
his State of the Union address during
the partial government shutdown but only
after a showdown with House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi over whether he should go
to Capitol Hill next week the president
tweeted this last night there is no
venue that can compete with the history
tradition and the importance of the
House chamber this is her prerogative I
look forward to giving a great State of
the Union address in the near future
speaker Pelosi responded mr. president I
hope by saying near future you mean you
will support the house-passed package to
end the shutdown that is one of two
competing measures the Senate will vote
on today 34 days after the shutdown
began Nancy cortices on Capitol Hill
with the rare concession from the
president Nancy good morning good
morning in the reality is that here's
how it works with the State of the Union
address the president cannot give a
speech to a joint session of Congress
unless the House and Senate pass a
resolution setting out the date and time
first and the Democratic House Speaker
had now made it clear that that is not
going to happen until the shutdown is
over they've become a radicalized party
President Trump called speaker Pelosi's
move a block on the country she doesn't
want the American public to hear what's
going on the two exchanged pointed
letters Wednesday the president
insisting there are no security concerns
regarding the State of the Union address
so he looks forward to seeing you on the
evening of January 29th Pelosi responded
that the house would not authorize his
address until government has opened I
wrote to him the second time to say
since government has shut down the
driver let's let's work together a
mutually agreeable date and we can
welcome you to the Capitol together in a
State of the Union address as they
argued furloughed federal workers
descended on Capitol Hill
[Applause]
the Senate will vote today on two
competing proposals a Republican bill
that would give the president his 5.7
billion dollars in border wall funding
and a democratic proposal that would
reopen the government through February
8th but with no wall money it's time to
make a deal both bills are likely to
fail leaving Americans like Mallory
largely bischoff from River Falls
Wisconsin in limbo she's a furloughed
Fish and Wildlife Service employee and a
diabetic
she's started rationing her insulin
because she can't afford her co-pays you
hit rock bottom and um you know things
you didn't never thought you would do or
the thoughts that come to your mind
after sharing her story online
Bischoff received donations of both
money and insulin it's wonderful that so
many people are so generous but on the
flip side they shouldn't be put in that
position to begin with House Democrats
are working on a proposal that would
give the president's a five billion
dollars for border security measures but
it would be for things like drones and
personnel and not for a wall so we'll
see where that goes Nora because the
president has said before that it's a
wall or nothing I wonder if there's a
compromise there Nancy thank you